cientos de ciclistas han salido a las
calles de madrid en cinco
manifestaciones distintas para pedir que
este medio sostenible asequible y
saludable sea además seguro no se
respetó a los carriles bici no están
bien señalizados y al final la bici se
que sale perdiendo ante un coche un
autobús evidentemente la bici pierde me
gustaría que estarían más alejados a los
coches porque
te puedes llevarlos es que te pueden
atropellar cuando vas a girar
en general las ciudades españolas están
muy poco preparadas para los
desplazamientos en bicicleta comparado
con ciudades como bogotá que cuentan con
más de 560 kilómetros de ciclorrutas
madrid o barcelona apenas rondan los 200
estamos claramente muy detrás de otras
ciudades españolas y desde luego de
otras ciudades europeas lo que
necesitamos para impulsar la bicicleta
de una vez por todas es hacer eso todo
eso no es vida ciclistas seguras cómodas
y solo que no sean discontinuas que se
puede desde un sitio
ve directamente en la capital española
los desplazamientos en bicicleta sólo
representan el 0 5% del total una cifra
muy alejada del 10% que se ha puesto
como objetivo españa para el año 2030